it's plastic it's most likely beige and
it sounds like this chances are if you
grew up in the United States you've
played a recorder it was a non
negotiable part of your elementary
school education and for that you can
thank this guy Carl Orff a passionate
German composer originally the recorder
was handcrafted wooden and made for the
highest of society even Vivaldi and Bach
wrote pieces for the recorder it doesn't
rely on a reed or strings just breath
it's in the flute family in the 1960s
the recorder started being produced out
of plastic cheap plastic so how did it
become the clumsy awkward sound we all
used to play that's where Orff comes in
he saw the recorder as an easy way to
get kids to start playing music the
logic was simple the recorder relies on
rhythm rather than memorization if you
can sing you most likely can play it or
have had the best of intentions to
inspire the next generation of musicians
and even though they can sometimes be
annoying our hats are off to you sir
for changing the course of music
education for generations to come
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Peace Love and rock and roll
it's the hippie creed along with some up
flower power and some crunchy granola
and we call hippies crunchy granola
because of well granola the link between
the people the culture and the granola
it started in 1969 at Woodstock
organizers estimated that 200,000
fun-loving people would build a small
town of Bethel New York for the
three-day historic festival but the
number of attending doubled and the next
thing they knew there were over 400,000
people camping out which led to
shortages food shortages and well that
looked the munchies craving free loving
hippies a little angry this is where the
savior Hugh Romney came in Hugh and his
commune hog farm were hired to help
organizers run the festival upon seeing
the food shortage they stepped in to
help they rounded up a group of
volunteers hit the streets and came back
with you guessed it granola
members of hog farm filled the tons of
cups and Hugh took the stage and
announced there would be breakfast in
bed
400,000 the hippies ate it up and for
many it was their first introduction to
the crunchy stuff and so there you have
it the original bond between crunchy
granola and hippies was formed by
granola at the one-and-only
Woodstock Music Festival
[Applause]
[Music]
let's play a game
think of a famous painting guess what
you just thought of me today I'm the
world's most renowned work of art but it
wasn't always this way my story is full
of surprises and it all began in a
studio in Florida
[Music]
well here's the master himself Leonardo
da Vinci he worked on me on and off for
a few years towards the end of his
career you're a minor work my dear some
interesting shading nothing more we'll
just see about that
over the next 300 years
I hung quietly in French palaces and
royal bathrooms the things I've seen
Oh until finally I was noticed by a man
who had already made quite a name for
himself when Napoleon chose me to hang
on his bedroom while people took notice
I look forward to sleeping with you
master he after he had his whole exile
from France thing they tossed me on a
wall at the Louvre but at this point I
was still just another Renaissance
portrait until one night
Menma I was stolen it was pandemonium
Paris was in an uproar
the police hauled people in left and
raped the hysteria hit a fever pitch
when the police suspected and
interrogated one of the most famous
artists in the world Pablo Picasso
Jacques Jews the Picasso was innocent
the thief turned out to be an Italian
carpenter he was cotton flooring and I
returned to the Louvre from that day
forward I became the darling of the art
world everyone wanted to see Napoleon's
da Vinci painting Picasso was suspected
of stealing soon tourists crowded in and
most people forgot why I was famous in
the first place
that might raise some eyebrows but not
mine since I don't have any oh you
didn't notice I don't have any eyebrows
I told you I'm full of surprises country
music and grabbing your partner for a
dose IDO you probably have a fuzzy
memory of trying to master these moves
in middle school gym class am i right so
why were we all forced a couple up and
endure this embarrassment well it's all
thanks to Henry Ford now grab your
partner and dosey doe he was the father
of the car and the assembly line but
here's a little-known fact Henry Ford
loved to dance especially with his wife
Clara square dancing has deep roots in
American culture dating back to colonial
times
it remained popular until the waltz and
polka went mainstream in the 19th
century so in the 1920s for took it upon
himself to revive the old tradition
let's do it y'all he opened a Ballroom
in its hometown and encouraged his
factory workers and their families to
take part he felt square dancing helped
teach manners exercise values and grace
soon after he worked to create a
national square dancing program Boards
of Education across the country started
endorsing Ford's mission and since then
students have been taught to square
dance today 24 states still love square
dancing as their official state dance so
if you feel like reliving awkward gym
class moments I'm sure you can find
square dancing lessons somewhere nearby
all jump up and never come down swing
you're pretty good
round and round mothers Danny the one
day a year are people all over the world
paid tribute to mom MA mum or MA but how
did it all begin
enter Anna Jarvis the founder of
mother's day who came to despise her own
holiday Anna Jarvis really really loved
her mother her mother dies in 1905 and
in 1907 she really starts this campaign
that we need to have a day in honor of
what mothers do
let's dr. Catherine Angelini she's an
historian and wrote a book about Anna
she always identified herself as an ER
vez the founder of mother's day and in
1914 after six years and state-by-state
campaigning Jarvis's dream came true
President Woodrow Wilson officially
designated a second Sunday of May as
Mother's Day arrey right
Jarvis felt Wilson was taking credit for
her efforts and he wasn't the only
source of her ire Anna had a really
wonderful enemies list she was mad at
the candy industry she was mad at the
floor industry she was mad at all these
charities she also turned in some of her
early allies including John Wanamaker a
business tycoon who saw a commercial
opportunity and Mother's Day he started
putting the holiday on everything even
dishes at his restaurant
Jarvis did not approve
she ordered this mother stay solid and
once the Sal arrived mrs. Jarvis has
dumped it on the floor and walked out
that was not what the day was supposed
to be what exactly was the day supposed
to be so it really wasn't meant to be go
out rush off buy all these flowers and
greeting cards and candy and gifts just
go home and spend the day with your
mother that's all she wants I wonder
what Anna Jarvis would say about the way
Mother's Day celebrated today she would
still be defending it against
commercialization we celebrate this
holiday in ways that she doesn't think
we should he was that people don't
forget about Anna Jarvis the mother of
Mother's Day and please send your mom a
card
for her a greeting card would be
insincere it would be cheap it would be
lazy if you can't go home
then you know write a letter to her not
to send a card got it right your mama
handwritten letter she deserves it don't
you think
[Music]
if you know Donuts you know the pink
donut box especially if you're familiar
with Southern California which has
hundreds of donut shops most with the
pink boxes but while you may recognize
the box you may not know it's central to
a story about chasing the American dream
[Music]
the pink box phenomenon all started with
a man named Ted Ted Noi came to
California as a Cambodian refugee in the
1970s he got into the donut business and
became the owner of dozens of shops had
sponsored other refugees have taught
them the business and helped them open
their own shops since Ted used the pink
boxes so did everybody else Ted became
known as the donut king my name is maily
Chow and I am these donor princes of La
[Music]
the donut princess is great uncle the
one and only donut king Ted Noi
he taught me Lee's parents a business in
the 1980s and they started this shop
Meili took it over a few years ago and
beyond mainly Ted's legacy lives on
through you guessed it those pink boxes
when we came to LA my parent owned a
doughnut shop for 26 years
we used to paint dota boxes
in the Asian community red is the lucky
color so therefore using the pink box
it's no coincidence about it the pink
box is overwhelmingly the favorite of
the donut shop industry that's Len bell
he should know his company manufactures
about 12 to 15 million donut
every year Cheers well the pink foxes
are still an iconic part of the donut
landscape owners are putting a new spin
on things
mailee makes some of the same doughnuts
her parents used to make but like
everything times are a-changin when I
took the business over for my parents
they were using the generic pink boxes
that you see everywhere but our
doughnuts were not generic and I needed
to reflect that upon our new upgraded
boxes and what is your mom think about
that Meili my mom does not really
approve him for the new boxes they're a
little bit more expensive and it's not
really what she's used to
but I think it's a sign of new donut
times YUM sounds delicious
you
[Music]